so to see this hierarchy
this constructive hierarchy
began to bother me
and it bothered me in the following
sense
um in the study of life one of the
things that's been
really interesting in the last half
century is beginning to realize that
life as
Erwin Schrodinger suggested
is a process that's far from equilibrium
means it maintains itself far from
equilibrium
can you define that term far from
equilibrium so at equilibrium it's it's
where a system will fall to so to speak
degrade to
um if left alone that is what happens is
the system will fall to its lowest
energy State
um until it's prevented from falling
into a lower energy State
um
in in terms of entropy where we
oftentimes think about this
um a system that's well mixed
is at its lowest state it can't be more
mixed uh once you pour your
cream into your coffee and you stir it
well enough it's well mixed and it's
almost impossible to go backwards to
unmix it
um
that's in its highest energy state so
room temperature mug would be at
equilibrium with the so room temperature
mug is now it's you might say that its
temperature the liquid is now the
temperature in the liquid is now well
mixed with its environment
so it's at equilibrium that is there's
no shift it there's no asymmetry between
them
um the same thing is two of the coffee
in your mug that you've stirred
um what happens or the ink dropped into
water the stern becomes equally
distributed no part
um is significantly different than any
other part
whereas when the coffee is first hot or
when I first pour in the cream now
there's a separate gradient of
difference between the two parts that
gets eliminated over time that happens
spontaneously and this is the second law
of Thermodynamics of course played out
in different ways that is things go
towards equilibrium where gradients of
difference if they're not constrained
they will break down
those differences will dissipate over
time okay okay so the hot cup is far
from equilibrium with respect to a
colder room so why is the terminology
called far from equilibrium rather than
just saying not in equilibrium if for
example think about my refrigerator
my refrigerator does work to keep its
internal relationship far from
equilibrium with respect to the
environment we usually talk about far
from equilibrium as things being having
really high gradients of difference
so being away from equilibrium most of
thermodynamics was developed in what we
call mere equilibrium conditions
conditions where things are a little bit
off from equilibrium but we'll tend to
fall towards equilibrium
um by I say fall towards equilibrium is
that a precise term to be
near equilibrium versus far from
equilibrium or does it depend on the
context well of course it's it's it's
near and far are of course not not
quantitative terms
so when we say near near equilibrium
we're dealing with a whole range of
processes in which the gradient of
difference is not huge
because when the gradient is is large
some very unusual things can happen
uh and this has produced a whole series
of studies that have really been going
on for more than a century now about
unusual features that happen far from
equilibrium
um uh so an example are shock waves
shock waves in which normally
differences in pressure
even out pretty pretty quickly winds and
difference in pressure in different
parts of the globe for example our
differences in pressure when you're you
know inflating a balloon uh and then
letting it sort of out
um these things dissipate pretty quickly
and easily but you can push things so
far
that the normal processes don't
dissipate that pressure so breaking the
sound barrier is a classic example
pressure can be moved from one part of a
of the air to another part of the air to
equilibrate the pressure pretty quickly
and easily it can do so
without much of a problem
up to the speed of sound
the sounds that I'm producing now are
the result of pressure waves
that could be transmitted across
space in an atmosphere because of the
way the pressure waves
produce other pressure waves
and pass this along
those sound waves are the result of the
fact that this this is how fast pressure
wave pressure differentials move through
the atmosphere
so however you can
because
the atoms in the in the air the
molecules in the air
um can only bump into each other so hard
so fast to move this
there are certain speeds above the speed
of sound we say that now breaks this so
you now can't actually have the pressure
dissipate across this boundary where
this pressure is so high that the air
can't disperse it fast enough
the result is when a jet breaks the
sound barrier
um it creates a
break in the atmosphere so to speak a
boundary in which there's high pressure
air on one side low pressure air on the
other side and it can't be relieved
it's only as the pressure decreases the
pressure differential decreases
some distance away from the jet that
suddenly it can release and it releases
in a huge bang a sonic boom and this is
because now finally we've come back to
the level at which that pressure can be
released and it's a huge differential
and it's released rapidly a loud sound
um so what's happened here is that far
from equilibrium
we've pushed it so far that it can't
re-equilibrate right away
and so beginning at the turn of the
century and particularly after the
mid-century last century
um studying systems that are very far
from equilibrium began to produce all
kinds of interesting results
so we notice for example one of the
things that on the wings of jets
um as they're far from equilibrium also
they produce
um put them out to whirlpools
um vortices and the vortices are also
playing a role in in dispersing this
energy differential in different ways
and the vortices can actually mess up
your flight and one of the real problems
with breaking the sound barrier
initially was all the vortices that were
produced as you be as you approached
this
critical point
um really destabilized everything and so
there's a lot of shuddering you know in
the the first flights beyond the sound
barrier they were afraid it was going to
rip apart the jet
um turns out that it it it's not enough
to do that and we find find out how to
go go beyond that but but subsequently
what we discovered is that systems that
we now maintain far from equilibrium we
don't allow it to equilibrate can
produce all kinds of interesting effects
and one of the things that they do is
they produce orderly effects
now why do I say orderly
um
one of the one of the best examples of
this that everybody knows is a Whirlpool
we just talked about the vortices at the
end of of the wings of jets a whirlpool
in a stream
um what's happening is that you start
the water flowing down the stream
and it comes and runs into say a a
barrier of some kind going around the
barrier
it produces all kinds of irregularity
lots of unstable
um behaviors
the flow is no longer laminar it's now
broken up and and you get chaotic flows
but as the water continues the chaotic
flows begin to cancel out
um and whirlpools form
the whirlpool forms because all the
chaotic interactions
um are in a sense contrary to each other
because they're not all in the same
direction they begin to cancel each
other out
and so that over time all the
non-symmetric interactions begin to
cancel out and those are non-symmetric
are the only ones that are left and that
produces the laminar flow that becomes a
Whirlpool that actually allows water to
move through this
this barrier more efficiently uh and one
of the things we know about whirlpools
for example uh think about bathtubs
being drained and producing a Whirlpool
the whirlpool actually
um because it aligns the movement of
water molecules so they're not in each
other's way so to speak that they're
minimally out of each other's way
um it more effectively more efficiently
empties the bathtub the bathtub is of
course now a gradient of difference the
gravity that's pulling the water down
that gradient is being dissipated but
it's spontaneously because it's such a
high gradient it spontaneously forms
into a Whirlpool because it more rapidly
depletes that gradient the whirlpool by
virtue of allowing spontaneously
non-interacting non-contradicting
movements to be slowly eliminated
um now empties the bathtub faster so if
you were sitting in the bathtub and then
just messing up the whirlpool constantly
um and now compare bring that to a
bathtub in which you didn't do that
messing up the whirlpool would allow it
to drain more slowly
the whirlpool actually
um as system is far from equilibrium
like this moves towards equilibrium by
regularizing the flow those are called
dissipative structures or dissipative
systems is there a difference between
those two what I'm saying is you're
dissipating the gradient in this case
right
but if you have a strong gradient
sometimes and particularly if that
gradient is maintained for a long period
of time like a full bathtub or a stream
that keeps running okay then what
happens is you're constantly dissipating
that gradient but the gradient doesn't
get dissipated right right so under
those circumstances what happens is it
tends to fall into irregularity because
the regularity
reduces what you might call the
dissipation
length
how far a molecule has to travel before
it leaves okay if it has to if it
travels and it gets bumped back and it
travels and gets bumped back
by virtue of chaotic interactions it's
going to take longer to to leave and
that means the trajectory of its
departure say from the bathtub
um is longer it's going to take longer
take more time so what happens in
systems that are maintained far from
equilibrium is they generally
develop interregularities
uh now here's here's the issue this is
why way back in the 1940s the quantum
physicist Erwin Schrodinger said this
has got to be relevant to life
because life is maintained far from
equilibrium
because life is taking in fuel
to keep pumping it far from equilibrium
yeah he talked about this as you know as
neg entropy you know if entropy is the
increase of this process he says maybe
they have to eat an egg entropy that
food is like neg entropy pushing it I
think it's a bad term and most people
have have abandoned it but the idea I
think is right and that is in order to
stay far from equilibrium because a
system that is far from equilibrium is
dumping energy as fast as it can
in order to stay far from equilibrium
you have to keep pumping up that
gradient
so the stream has to keep running
or maybe you have to heat something
constantly to keep it far from
equilibrium or like in your refrigerator
you have to keep a motor running that
dumps heat constantly because the
refrigerator is is spontaneously trying
to fall towards equilibrium
but you've got to do work
to constantly push it away from
equilibrium
to stay far from equilibrium you have to
do work
so that of course is relevant for life
and what happened since then and a lot
of systems thinking about life fell into
I think this error thinking that we're
just like a whirlpool
we're just like a very complicated
Whirlpool we get energy and we bump it
out and therefore our regularity is like
that
it turns out that that's a really useful
insight
because it says you know to be what we
are we have to do this
but it's incorrect it doesn't quite go
far enough
to generate all the regularities that we
have requires work
to generate
all the gradients different molecular
systems in our body all different cell
types all the different molecular
interactions it requires constant work
and of course so it's you might say in
that respect it's like an extremely
complicated uh Whirlpool
um but in fact that's not quite the case
because the story with a Whirlpool or
all all far from equilibrium
physical systems
is that they're in the process of
destroying themselves
they're in the process of getting rid of
the gradient as fast as possible
they spontaneously regularize in the
process of dumping that gradient as fast
as possible
life has to be just the opposite of that
light hat life has to generate these
gradients and keep it
from undermining itself
self-organizing systems like this
are self-destructive by Nature
living systems are constantly involved
in trying to keep that from happening
so here's the Paradox a living system
has to use self-organizing like
processes dissipative processes
to generate the order it has
and yet it has to use those dissipative
processes
to keep those dissipative processes from
destroying themselves
that's a really interesting paradox
we've we're self-organizing
but we're using our self-organization to
keep the self-organization from falling
apart
how could that possibly be you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy